once upon a time there was a temple he
was pretty dope three goddesses lived
there the truth goddess who always told
the truth the lie goddess who lied down
a lot but also was a huge liar and the
wisdom goddess who sometimes lied and
sometimes told the truth
weirdly all three looked exactly the
same so nobody could tell them apart one
day a traveler came by and he was like
yo I got a dentist appointment can you
guys move the goddess's said you may
only pass if you can tell us apart
so give it a shot I guess he asked the
goddess on the left who's the middle
goddess truth she replied he asked the
goddess in the middle who are you wisdom
she answered he asked the goddess on the
right who is the middle goddess she's
the liar the goddess replied the man
made his dentist appointment that day
and boy did his teeth Sparkle how did he
tell the goddesses apart I have no idea
I am Marty terrible so like a fun a
friend option I feel like the middle
goddess would say yes everything I don't
really give up too easily if you ask the
goddess Dalai he's like if you go hey
like what color is my shirt like you're
wearing like a white shirt and the
goddess says so like you're wearing a
black shirt like you know she's lying
wisdom sometimes says what boy little of
each we'll each that's not very helpful
if she is truth then she can't be saying
that the other girl is truth that could
still make that one truth still telling
the truth no no no no no no no and then
you'll figure out that's the truth God
is and then to the left is the line God
is also just let you know I'm real tired
liar middle wisdom right truth of wisdom
like truth left I think I said was
wisdom middle was lying and right was
truth is that true is it is I the answer
here you
go ahead just tell to me the left
goddess is wisdom the middle goddess is
lying and the right goddess is truth the
goddess on the Left said the middle one
is truth so the left cannot be truth
because there cannot be two truth
goddesses the goddess in the middle said
she was wisdom in that case she cannot
be truth or she would have said so so
the goddess on the right must be truth
and according to her the middle one is
lie as a result the goddess on the left
is wisdom
you